bill burrs new series is f is for family
premieres on Netflix coming up Friday
he's on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon tomorrow night on Conan on
Wednesday look at you that's right a
media boy look good she I'm throwing up
doing the town I didn't think we could
get you back you know we had you when
you were hungover maybe you didn't
realize what you were doing that's the
second time you brought that up that
buzzy minute it bugged you I went out I
had a few what do you when old school no
I liked it
all right oh no no I'm fine we were
probably hungover - yeah you know I wish
I was tell you I was a good boy last
night last night I had one beer and an
appetizer that was it I'm being a
professional but I'm on clear right look
at me dead are you funnier when you're
sober or likes a night I never I never
go on stage with any you only to two
times in my life I've ever gone on stage
like legally drunk one was in Ireland
which just happens you're that's not
legally yeah that's being in Ireland
yeah and then the other time I went to a
Yankees game and you know I got hammered
and then I was coming back to the city
and I thought I was sober and somebody
goes hey I got a show you want to jump
on and I'm like am sober enough and I
went up there and it just did not go
well at all at all I was instantly
bombing and like whatever I was doing
like 15 years at that point all of that
experience went just out the window so
no I don't do that but then it's almost
like an out-of-body experience like
you're doing it and then there's another
part of you that says you shouldn't be
doing this right now
oh yeah but the bombing is always not
out-of-body you always feel that getting
hammered by the crowd and I'm just
standing there like now this is
definitely happening to me I don't feel
like this is happening to somebody else
so but which I don't mind bombing if I'm
trying something new but if I'm bombing
because of that I've only did it twice
and I had tremendously tremendously
unprofessional it's just nuts I won't
you know I don't care if it's four hours
before I'm going on I never mess with
that stuff but afterwards you know you
know hold on stay how is stand-up
changed um or has it changed well I
think comedy crowds are way more
educated
- comedy as far as like you know half
the crowd is made a YouTube video at
this point tried to make it funny and
then got either good reviews or got
shredded and you actually learn what
plays like I know a bunch of people
ripped off was the the Dave Chappelle
thing will you do the joke and then you
show in slow motion and then more in
slow motion that literally became a
style for like these videos so like
people in the crowd you started seeing
regular people from the crowd making
videos using the influence of the
Chappelle show so um like you you really
have to disguise the jokes more like you
have to live before you let them over
here and then BAM you went like that now
I feel like you got a welcome to like a
whole football field and then bring it
all the way around or else they're
already standing at the finish line
which does not work as a joke then then
you become like a you see what I did
there and people start going hi Oh in
the crowd you just feel like a cornball
that's press probably the worst heckle
the Ed McMahon higher that it's just
like that means that joke stunk and it
would have bombed in 1971 and that's the
brute that's the worst one I saw that
guy opened for me at an improv and he
was just by I hate seeing people bomb
unless it's a friend of mine I know
they're funny then it's hilarious but I
saw this newer guy and he was bombing it
was like three or four in a row and then
he finally did one of those Tonight Show
jokes from the early 70s and it was dead
silence and some guy just goes hi oh and
I was just I am literally it like hurt
my rib cage just like oh god this guy
this guy might not be back this might be
his final set how are you watching the
Patriots games like last night it's kind
of a boring game yeah it's very boring
game uh well I mean JJ Watts wasn't he
wasn't healthy I mean his arm all
wrapped up and everything like that um
how do i watch him I mean you know if
I'm on the road obviously I'll tape the
game then I'll watch it but uh I am
excited that we lost a couple of games
you know because when we were undefeated
that was like an albatross around our
neck and we got busted for the cheating
so then we were like all right this is
what we could have been doing and then
we ran up the score and I fell from
October on we were playing a playoff
game because we started embarrassing
people so being undefeated on the East
Coast I've noticed is way more pressure
than doing it in like Indianapolis or
like South Carolina like I feel like
this should be way more
pressure on Carolina right now like are
you gonna do it yeah are you gonna do
what the Patriots couldn't quite do and
blah blah blah blah blah bu just sort of
oh it's tits Carolina you know things
are easy down there it's laid back
he's bill burr actor comedian the new
series f is for family it's Netflix this
Friday
he's on The Tonight Show which should be
found tomorrow night then Conan on
Wednesday do you know what you're going
to do on Fallon and Conan right now uh I
have no idea for Conan but for Fallon I
just did a pre-interview so they sort of
like walkie this basically the game plan
in that weird and it goes out the window
yeah cuz I can't do like the I think if
you're bombing on those shows they
stayed they stick with the cue card and
then it's like blah blah blah blah blah
and you do a little thing that it's just
sort of like so do you ever mow a lawn I
got it raining like a matter of fact I
haven't it comes off like they have like
ESP and then that's that's when it's
just terrific and if you look you can
see it in both of their eyes like this
isn't going well this isn't going well
so I try to it's kind of how I do my
stand-up back where I sort of walk out I
some nights I don't know what I'm gonna
say some ice I'm just sick of my ex so I
just gonna like I'm not gonna tell I'm
gonna try to go as long as I can without
doing any of my act which then makes you
present in the room that you're in so I
try to use some of those tools when you
when you do the Tonight Show but I've
never done The Tonight Show so I'll see
Conan's fun because calling grew up
Massachusetts same neck of the woods
that I did you know he's a little bit
older than I am but we're roughly I feel
like was roughly the same thing Jimmy
I've never done his show but you know
he's like super positive up guy and I'm
more of a curmudgeon so I think maybe
we'll have a nice Odd Couple thing you
know but I love Jimmy I've known him
forever so I think it's gonna be fun I
went on Leno and it and I could tell
where they you know they said you know
yeah stay on script here you know you
got to stay with what the questions are
and you know so he knows how to respond
and then I realized it's it's not going
great and I went rogue oh yeah oh yeah
when you saw the light turn back on his
face oh here we are we want to show him
and then we got done and it was it was
greeted with like tepid response
it was yeah oh yeah good job young okay
come back and I realized that it's it's
not going well
byah it went well after I went rogue
because then I just said I let me go
back to something I know that's gonna
have some fun right and then you know
the crowd responded cuz I'm walking out
there and they're going who's this guy
you know tonight a sportscaster okay
what are you gonna talk about and then
jails here I'm Superboy okay and then
you're going I don't want to talk about
that right
and Letterman's this but Letterman will
go off script too
I know I can't even get it back I never
did panel on a show I only did stand-up
which was which was always there was an
element of terror involved because he
doesn't put his arm around you and you
stink he's not gonna come up and save
you good job good job II just kind of
like hilber and then we just walk off
and he be like yeah I deserve that so
like you know I've always really
respected guys like that I hate that
doing that I but I like it that you know
that if you actually make them laugh
like one of the big thrills was to hear
him when he would laugh at Letterman
yeah and what people didn't realize was
he felt like he was that far away cuz
the way they shot that show is like the
monologue Paul Shaffer and Letterman was
over there and when I watched it at home
I mean it felt like it was you know like
miles apart but it's like he's like
right there you keep half a step over he
could shake hands with Paul so is a
really really like intimate thing but
the best was when they put the cameras
to the back of the crowd so there wasn't
that like that barrier used to be like
you know the TV cameras right there then
on the other side of them was the crowd
was really hard to connect with them
once they put them in the back was it
was a really nice gig have you ever done
white man cliches in sports cuz we do it
all the time I was doing my podcast when
I was watching the Celtics game uh I
just sometimes if I'm just bored out if
I'm the podcast not going well I'll just
put on some sports and I start
commentating so like I yeah i do cliches
don't give it to the white guy don't
give it does that for course he missed
it and then he fouls them what else is
he gonna do so I like I definitely do
stuff like that and joke around that
watching NBA hoop gives you low self
Steve's a white guy and I can't remember
the last time we were on the good side
of the poster Rose that guy oh you were
always the duh Washington general guy
yeah uh you're like Sean Bradley getting
you know posterized er I know I know and
I think that's why they were jumping all
over that kid from the mix I'm sorry I
don't know his name is yeah cuz he had
sort of that build and it just had all
the makings of that so I was really
psyched that he's doing as well as he is
that he's European I know that's that's
like white guy 2.0 yeah that's a bear
yeah not fair we really haven't had a
good American white guy since Larry Bird
am i nuts like just some guy like people
actually that classic white guy he can't
jump he's not fast but for some reason
we can't stop this guy so it's been a
while well he's intelligent he's he's
gritty and he's gutti oh is that what
they say coach's son hard worker high
motor first guy to the gym last yeah of
course he is
have you met bird no I have how would
that go if I met Larry Bird I've ever
imagined it would be if I said Brady er
bird Larry Bird oh there but without a
doubt there Larry Bird is like you know
he was a god like all this generation of
athletes once you get to a certain age
and they're younger than you they just
remind you that yeah you're never gonna
make it the NFL you know I mean like
yeah that's it that guy was born in the
70s you were born in the 60s it's
officially over no Matt you can't even
be a placekicker so um I obviously don't
love Tom Brady and all those guys but
yeah Larry Bird Larry legend come on
what about Don Rickles or Larry Bird Oh
Don Rickles really well yeah Don Rickles
hung out with Sinatra you got one
question to ask Don Rickles who killed
Kennedy
you think he knows well yeah well you
hung out with Sinatra six degrees of
separation he's probably knows yeah why
not
where's Jimmy Hoffa that's one of those
you know you know yes comes free mob
questions one of them he's got the
answer to you think he's overheard
things is what you say I don't chances I
uh I don't know well if you talk to some
of those old I'm actually reading a
great book right now and like the
history of stand-up comedy somebody just
sentiment sent it to me and
about all those supper clubs that the
mob ran and all that type of stuff it
was crazy they had some guy that he made
the mistake of either his contract ran
out or it didn't run out and he went to
a different supper color Club and
performed that was run by a different
family and they damn near beat him to
death like he had to learn how to talk
again like they cut him like tongue
hanging out of his neck and stuff is a
comedian way to bring things down here
Billy
well you know you say that you're
positing that for Fallon man could that
have been interesting bill you know what
you've been doing this long enough the
second I brought up killing Kennedy you
should have known the direction I was
going you know I'm driving you I tried
to stop it there I went off run went
rogue I'm sorry I went rogue
assassination humor is awesome you know
gotta love assassination humor bills new
series is f is for family it's Netflix
this Friday and he will show off on the
Fallon show The Tonight Show tomorrow
night and then Conan on Wednesday uh I
am happy for your success I really am oh
thank you I am because seaton over there
is a fanboy he's the one who brought to
you to art you know you know you to our
attention and been able to follow and
it's been great
Oh a lot of fun I appreciate it but so
you trying to bring it back feel good
yeah well hey I've been a big fan of
yours okay that no nice bow no no no it
is all meant I'll tell you what I'll
tell you what you were part of the the
only jet last generation of sports
anchors on ESPN that knew the highlight
wasn't about them you did you joke you
got in and you got out now you got these
guys they literally screaming over great
plays and it drives me nuts
I don't watch ESPN that much I've been
nice if you said that and then I
complimented you you want to do it over
again can I do is it this thing's on a
delay is gonna see you you know that's
you that's the dark side of you that you
didn't want to say something nice I get
it but me I'm struggling Jimmy Fallon to
sit listen like this this is your inner
child and your mother didn't hug you and
now you put it on me cuz I didn't give
you a compliment yeah that's the right
thing yeah somebody's got to go first in
the compliment game so what he's saying
I always have to go first that's cunny
it's just nice as if you go first
okay well tell you what I said nice
things last time about you you could
have said that last time you were here
when you were hungover
it always comes back to that that's it
Billy I can't tell you being
passive-aggressive you're actually being
nicer I don't know I'm not the quickest
wit here he's a sober Bill burr and he's
a sober bill Berwick at some point can I
talk about the cartoon and not the the
assassination of one of our presidents
when to there it where's December 18th
you can watch all I mean are your
character in the show yes I do the voice
of Frank Murphy takes place in 1973 back
when you could slap your kid around take
a gun to the airport smoke in a car
right you just let your kids out tell
them to come back when the street lights
are on for some reason you can't do this
with real people you can't do this in
live action I think it'll it'll it'll
influence real kids but if you animate
it the Animus I feel like I'm insulated
from all these psycho bloggers where I
can be like well look this is how
animated people behaved in the early 70s
to be honest with you if yeah I mean it
is an adult series yeah we we do use
adult language and all that but uh you
know it has it you know it has the
honeymooners baby of the greatest moment
in the end which was a lot of my
childhood where we'll be like we look
like a Norman Rockwell painting and it
would be like hey let's go get a
Christmas tree well let's get so-and-so
a new bike so it was this wonderful
thing and then it was all the
dysfunction that happened between that
and then you riding down the street and
shaking off all the screaming and
yelling that you heard so um like it
that's basically the the premise behind
it and then it's also serialized which
was Netflix's brilliant idea so each
each episode leads into the next one so
I'm very proud of it
f is for family this Friday Laura darn
Sam Rockwell Justin Long look a David
Koechner look at you that's right okay
some big names heavy hitters heavy
hitters swinging the pipe bill bird
doing big boy things look at him well
dressed up doing the job you ha ha ha
take a break here Thank You Billy thank
you Dan
you know what I love your glasses thank
you Bill see that was first nice let's
say some of my jacket from the Han Solo
collection
we'll be back right after this